Moderate Muslims, and I don't care for
that word, and I don't care for the word
radical, because radical Muslims are not
radical. What they are is observant,
pious Muslims. And what we call moderate
are lackadaisical Muslims. Uh you know,
easygoing, secular, cultural cultural
Muslims, where yeah, you know, we we we
go we do the Ramadan thing, we we have a
feast, we go to the mosque once in a
while, that sort of thing. Some don't
even do any of that. So, but in no way,
shape, or form do these moderate
Muslims, as we call them, who do exist,
they are not representative of Islam,
okay? And that's the whole point. Same
thing you can say about like I said,
Christians and Jews and I mean, look, in
Judaism, you have the Orthodox Jews, you
have the secular or you know, reformed,
and obviously one will say one's not
doing it the right way, for example,
right? Yeah.
>> So, um
the the text, the teaching is what it
is. It is, by any measure, what we would
call radical and disturbing and
draconian. Um you know, the punishments
and the amputations and the whipping,
that's all part of Islam. Why? And we if
you want, we can get into it, but
because it's part of what's called
Sharia law, and Sharia law is based on
the literal words of the Quran, which
are believed to be from Allah,
and Muhammad's words and deeds, which
are many, and in the Quran says you have
a perfect example in Muhammad, and you
have to follow him, okay? And just to
show you what I'm talking about, in the
Quran, for example, there's a whole
there's this doctrine, which to me So,
you were asking me earlier, you know,
what's what's the most problematic
thing? One was of course the shock I you
know, this disconnect between what what
Muslims were really up to with the
Al-Qaeda, and what Westerners how like
not only were they clueless, but they
were actually disseminating their lies.
But the other one was this doctrine that
even until now no one really wants to
talk about. People will talk about
jihad. To me, the most problematic
doctrine, in Arabic it's called al-wala
wal-bara, and these two words can be
translated in various ways from they can
be called loyalty and enmity, they can
Some Muslims translate them as love and
hate, which is actually pretty good. And
with this doctrine, which is in the
Quran, teaches Muslims can only be must
only be loyal to fellow Muslims, the
ummah. Okay, they are their only
friends. And the non-Muslims, you have
to hate them.
Okay? And it even says even if they're
your fathers and your brothers and your
wives. I translated a video of a popular
Egyptian cleric, it's on my YouTube
channel, who says
I've seen this. No, no. You've seen it.
Where he's
>> it on your channel, but please tell the
Yeah, yeah, where he basically says, and
this is this is because of the teaching
of the hatred for non-Muslims. Islam
allows Muslim men to marry Christian
women and Jews cuz they're the people of
the book.
But it's also interesting because of
course a Christian man can't marry a
Muslim woman. Why? Because of course
they see it from a purely patriarchal
worldview, which is okay as long as it's
the as long as the woman is the infidel,
who cares? She's subjugated. Anyway,
that's why you can't have a male
Christian or Jew married to a Muslim
because you can't have a Muslim being
subjugated, right? But so he says
even though that's a legit, you have to
hate her in your heart and show her you
hate her. And he says you can enjoy her
sexually, you can enjoy her whatever
way, you know, but you make sure she
knows you hate her. I'll have you be
Can I get the charger for your car over
there?
He can manage any colonist would have to
go with them.
Come in and ask me what you have had
while I was here.
Huh? Well, my dad told her what to do
with her stuff. Oh, you have to be with
her and love her. Oh, you have to be
with her and love her. Whatever you got.
You got to have it to go with your baby
and have a nice day. That's a deal. I'm
going to
I'm going to be near you now. The guy
you have to be in You have to be with
her and love her. I have to be with her
and love her. You have to be in I'll
have you back. I'm going to be with her
and love her.
I'm going to be with her and love her.
I'm going to be with her. I'm going to
be with her and love her. I'm going to
I'm going to be with her and love her.
I'm going to be with her and love
>> Okay. And and and and here here here we
go to the moderate thing. Even in the
audience cuz he's given a he's
preaching. Some Muslims are find it hard
to reconcile this. These are who we
would call moderate.
But he says it's in the Quran. It's and
it is in the Quran. Okay? There's a
Quran Sura 60 verse 4 um says
Ibrahim, who's Abraham from Genesis, you
know you know Islam appropriates a lot
of these um uh biblical characters says
so the Genesis account God calls Abraham
and he leaves the land of Ur, okay? And
that's the end of it in the Islamic
account, not only does he do that, but
he tells his former kinsmen
and until until you believe in God
Allah, hatred will reign between us
forever. All right? And the Quran talks
about how these early pious Muslims
including the first caliph Abu Bakr and
Omar, the followers of Muhammad in wars
tried to kill their own relatives and
they did kill their own relatives. So
the whole point is loyalty belongs
exclusively to fellow Muslims. It's a
What what Muhammad did as I always say,
the genius of Muhammad
is he took the tribal mores of his
world, 7th century Arabia, and
rearticulated them through a theological
paradigm which made them so powerful. So
now normal tribalism which we understand
is you know me and my people and you're
the outsider, you're the enemy. But now
it's no longer my race or culture, it's
the ummah, it's Islam working together
as a body and everyone's the other tribe
and we're at war with them one way or
the other. Bring back
>> [music]
>> the fire.
Bring back
the fire
and the
righteousness.